i would say that almost every fifth mac
user is using at least one of our
products
now we're at macbook it's a tech company
that develops software for macros ios
and not only that platforms and now
we're in macbook company in kf and i'm
proud to show you like the zone where
people are working here and where make
paulians spend their time
[Music]
makpo is mostly famous by our main
product which is climber mac and
cleveland mark is a system utility that
helps users to
optimize their max to clean up
this space to make their in the top
operating performance
so basically it's like a system utility
to help
to maintain your mac in the best
operating conditions uh of course we
have many others like for example setup
this is like a first subscription app
store for a mac so for one price like
9.99 per month
you get access to more than 230
best tools for
for mac among other products we have an
ios product as well which is gemini
photos and this is like a utility to
help you maintain your
photo library in the best conditions so
we we find similar photos we have helped
to
find the best shots and clean up
unneeded ones
so
mostly we do system utilities for mac
and ios
[Music]
not only we have big meeting rooms but
also at tiny rooms and for example over
here you can see a sign that says
meeting or sleeping if the meeting sign
is turned on it means that somebody has
a meeting over there and if there is a
sleeping sign
yeah let's take a look into this room
this is a meditation room and as we at
macbook had hacky macathons
this is just a hackathon but we call it
hacky makathon when
like every six months um can develop and
create and do their own things and for
example about a year ago
there was a hackathon where guys wanted
to show the way into meditation well as
for me i'm not a meditating person and i
have no idea how to see it how to
breathe and how to do the things so guys
made an app
that showed how to do that there was a
guided meditation session or for example
you can set a timer and sleep
so one of those tiny cabins for sleeping
and meeting turned into a meditation
room
we have an i.t boom in ukraine nowadays
there are
many many many
startups and product companies and
outsourcing companies that are working
from ukraine and this is like a really
cool
source of experience and
knowledge for
future companies because
for example when the outsourced company
working with some western client
they receive
a lot of useful information regarding
the processes how to build products
what are the most i don't know
important features in the product etc
etc and over time
all of this experience stays and people
that work on that and that products
leave the outsourcing companies and may
join or even start their own product
companies and i think this is what is
happening right now in ukraine we have
many examples like this and this is
really positive
except this meditation room there was an
early hacker marketing project called
certui or sorry doubt in english it was
way sorted app and this solution was
only suitable for our
machine for our weight sorting station
some audience could understand how to
treat metal paper plastic or glass
but as lots of guests came to macpaw
they wanted to have the same solution
because it's tricky and confusing for
those who just start this recycling
process and people that just know don't
know how to sort out waste properly but
the quality of the app oh it was like an
in-house solution it wasn't that great
and we weren't ready to share it with
the world so we took another seven
months and created an app called sartui
uh sorted out
so
and now every mc4 fan can just give go
here pick what they want to throw out or
for example find the thing for example
i'm typing in that it is a paper cup
and yeah they say throw it over here
[Music]
we see our mission as the company that
helps
machines help people
so we create a software that optimizes
the hardware or the software or the
operating systems and this helps people
to become more productive and be able to
realize whatever they have in mind
and this is like the i think as a
mission of our company
before iphones before ipads before apple
started selling out its devices on the
fifth avenue in new york there was a
tech surf texture was it was often
called a first apple store
though it wasn't but it was the very
first place where happy owners of apple
computers could go and get their
computers fixed
and
this is the collection from that iconic
tech server this service center tech
server had been working for 29 years
in europe but like few years ago four
years ago to be exact
it was broke
and it collected a huge
[Music]
collection of 35 vintage mags in the
shop and the owners thought that they
won't find any place
or any
person who could acquire all those
computers all together so it won't end
up in a basement of some kind of
millionaire rich guy who doesn't want to
share this collection with the world
but
um
somebody at mcpostel's link senator ceo
and he said no like we have to get this
collection so make for one
and all those computers moved from new
york to kiev
and we've spent a summer to make them
all work for example
and on this laptop
it's
18 years old
and there is a very first version of
cleanmemec
the one that is still loved and acquired
by millions of users around the world
it's network
for me like business is not only about
the money and not only about business
results it's about
probably
[Music]
self-realization or
becoming what you are
so i personally think that i am an
engineer i am
the
some kind of inventor
and i really like to see how the ideas
happen from the idea and how they
materialize in some working applications
and some working projects and this is
what inspires me and
brings a lot of joy so for me this is a
driver and
i really enjoy that
i was already i was able to achieve that
[Music]
you